ein Mann kämpft um sein Lebenswerk um
sein Traumhaus mit dem improvisierten
Feuerwehrschlauch erhält Unterstützung
aus der Luft
Dave habe das Haus selbst gebaut erzählt
sein bester Freund Tod in einem
Videotelefonat der seinen Kumpel in
diesem Moment am Telefon drängt
verschwinde aus Killer
ich habe gesagt was machst du du musst
Weg seine Antwort ich bleibe und
beschütze mein Haus
trotz Heimat die Region im Südwesten
Kanadas brennt
der Ausblick aus seinem Schlafzimmer
ein schaurig schönes Schauspiel
[Musik]
mehr als zwei Kilometer See Wasser
liegen da noch zwischen seinem Haus und
den Bränden
ich habe mich sicher gefühlt von unserer
Veranda geschaut und war bisschen
verzweifelt weil wir nichts tun nicht
helfen konnten ich dachte bis zuletzt
auf keinen Fall kommt das Feuer über den
See bis brennende Tannenzapfen und
Baumrinde vom Himmel fielen
schnell brennen Bäume hinterm Haus in
Panik packt tot Kinder Katze und ins
Auto seine Frau alarmiert die Nachbarn
dann nur weg wie schnell das Feuer
kommen kann ist tot klar seit dem
brennenden auf Hawaii gerade zwei Wochen
ist das her doch schnell geht nicht mehr
[Musik]
ich habe mir Sorgen gemacht dass auf der
Straße nichts mehr vorwärts geht der
Verkehr Koch langsam wir haben einfach
nur gehofft dass wir schneller sind als
die Flammen zum Glück drückte der Wind
das Feuer in die andere Richtung weg von
uns es war beängstigend
Tod ist sicher bei seiner Schwester in
Vancouver untergekommen seiner Familie
geht es gut mehr als 1000 feuerwüten in
ganz Kanada 10.000 sind auf der Flucht
viele landen erstmal in Notunterkünften
wie hier in Edmonton Cara hat sich mit
ihrem Sohn über den brennenden Highway
gerettet ob Ihr Haus in yellow knife
noch steht niemand kann es ihr sagen
von dem was man so hört werden wir wohl
drei vier Wochen hier sein vielleicht
länger
je nachdem wie schwer das Feuer die
Stadt getroffen hat
ich mache mir Sorgen weil ich keine
Versicherung für das Haus habe
Waldbrände gehören zum saisonalen Alltag
in Kanada doch dieses Jahr stellt alles
in den Schatten die Flammen haben schon
doppelt so viel Waldfläche vernichtet
wie im bisherigen Rekordjahr 89
den Horror in Zahlen und Daten holen
sich viele Kanadier von Regierungsseiten
fast 6000 Brände in dieser Saison mehr
als 15 Millionen Hektar verbrannt das
entspricht was der Hälfte der Fläche
Deutschlands
Kanada ist riesig doch das Rot auf den
aktuellen Brandherd Karten der NASA
verspielt sich nicht mehr wie früher und
einer der führenden Klimaexperten
erklärt die Zukunft wird röter immer
längere Trockenperioden immer heißere
Sommer was wir da sehen und Kanada spürt
sein Folgen des Klimawandels
[Musik]
die Vegetation wird trocken das bietet
viel Nahrung für mehr Waldbrände in
Gegenden in denen es früher keine gab
oder nicht so schlimm und so brennt es
in neuen Regionen und häufiger außerdem
beobachten wir einen Anstieg bei den
sogenannten mega-feuern bei denen die
Flammen die Baumkronen erreichen und die
Bäume komplett vernichten und es wird so
heiß dass sie sich unglaublich schnell
ausbreiten das ist ein Stück weit ein
neues Phänomen das immer häufiger
vorkommen wird durch die höheren
Temperaturen
neue Studien untermauern den
wissenschaftlichen Konsens Brände dieses
Ausmaßes werden viel wahrscheinlicher
und das Gefühl dass die Klima extreme
und Ausschläge weltweit heftiger sind in
diesem Jahr es sei mehr als nur ein
Gefühl ein Klimaphänomen habe die
Temperatursteigerungen verzögert und
diese Phase sei nun vorbei
wir hatten drei Jahre lang Ninja was
äußerst selten ist dieses Phänomen hat
die Temperaturen weltweit niedrig
gehalten jetzt sind wir in ein stärker
werdendes Phänomen übergegangen mit
steigenden Temperaturen dazu kommt der
von Menschen verursachte Ausstoß von
Treibhausgasen dieser schnelle Wechsel
von El Ninja zu El Ninjo ließ die
Temperaturen rasant ansteigen und
beschert uns das wohl wärmste Jahr seit
Beginn der Aufzeichnungen
das System Klima sei komplex ergänzt
sieht hausfahrer aber die Katastrophen
werden sich häufen wenn in Sachen
CO2-Ausstoß nicht deutlicher umgesteuert
wird für Tod geht die brandsaison
glimpflich aus sein Haus liegt noch im
sperbereich aber ist verschont geblieben
die Feuer rund um gelohner sind unter
Kontrolle sie hätten Glück gehabt
diesmal